Підозрювані не встановлені,
обставини смерті не з’ясовані.Киянка Юлія Цепун
уже чотири роки у розпачі спостерігає,
як кримінальна справа щодозагибелі її чоловіка
Андрія Цепуна - героя Небесної сотні -
заходить у глухий кут.
Аби справу взагалі не закрили щеу 2014-ому,
жінці довелося оббігати не один кабінет: треба було
переконати слідчих, що висновок лікарів швидкої про смерть
від переохолодження, не відповідає дійсності.
Можна сказати, що нічого не робиться.
Завдяки адвокату ми зробили
повторну експертизу
стосовносмерті, там дуже багато недопрацювань.
Самі слідчі почали працювати...
лише через чотири місяці.
Вони все втратили,
потім півроку
перекладали з одного слідчого на іншого.
Юлія переконана, що її чоловіка викрали
тітушки,жорстоко побили
і викинули на узбіччі21 лютого.
Це сталося, коли Андрій повертався додому з майданівських барикад.
Під час Революції гідності чоловік був серед тих, хто
на в’їзді до Києва блокував машини з «беркутівцями».
Стояли металеві розтяжки у хлопців для пробиття шин
машин, щоб не давати
змогу в’їхати в Київ.
Вони не попускали «Беркут», тітушню
Смерть чоловіка, з яким прожила разом 15 років та виховувала сина,
Юлія пережила дуже важко. Каже, що хотіла
покінчити життя самогубством.
Почала повертатися до життя лише через півроку після смерті Андрія.
Тоді й зрозуміла, що слідчі просто проґаяли увесь цей час,
не вилучивши навіть відео з камер спостереження,
не опитавши свідків на блокпості,
не з’ясувавши у лікарів швидкої, чому вони не надали
невідкладну допомогу, адже чоловік
був ще живий, коли його знайшли.
Та найбільше жінку обурює те, що так само недбало
розслідують і загибель інших героїв Небесної сотні,
де є навіть ще більше фото та відеодоказів.
Може, хтось просто зацікавлений у тому,
щоб ці справи не рухалися,
щоб не були знайдені вбивці.
Не можу сказати
щодо некваліфікованих спеціалістів.
Я просто схиляюся до думки,
що слідство затягують, що комусь воно не вигідно.
Наразі до суду потрапилисправи про вбивства лише сорока шістьох
Героїв Небесної сотні. Юлія вже зневірилася
і не чекає від суду вироків, де пролунали б
прізвища всіх винних у загибелі євромайданців.
Жінка вирішила, що присвятить
свою діяльність збереженню пам’яті про усіх Героїв Небесної Сотні.
Тому стала співробітником
Національного музею Революції гідності, будівництво
якого планують розпочати наступного року
біля колись залитої кров’ю майданівців
вулиці Інститутської.